[Music]
and when I talk about this city feeling
unsafe for so many
it's because as a husband as a father as
a father raising three children on the
west side of Chicago I've had to Shield
my children
from bullets that fly right outside our
front door
welcome back and that is Chicago's mayor
elect Brandon Johnson in his victory
speech on Tuesday night the progressive
Democrat won the job by less than 20
thousand votes making it the closest
Mayoral race in the city in 40 years
he's a former teacher who campaigned on
fighting crime by invest by investing in
Schools jobs and mental health mayor
like Brandon joins us now from Chicago
good morning to you and congratulations
mayor elect good to see you hey good
morning thanks for having me
you were largely considered an underdog
going into this race and it really was a
come from behind win so congratulations
on that but now you got to get to the
job of doing the job and let's talk
about your plans and of course crime
being the biggest issue perhaps in most
major cities but front and foremost in
Chicago why is crime so bad
well first of all you know unfortunately
for too long the people of Chicago and
quite frankly people all over the
country have been given a false choice
on how we actually deal with Public
Safety
um what our campaign proved is that you
can actually demonstrate
um in a real way how critical
Investments are the necessary
Dynamics in order to prevent crime I
mean that's the ultimate goal is to
prevent crime and as I indicated in my
victory speech you know my wife and I
were raising three beautiful children on
the west side of Chicago it's a
beautiful neighborhood it's the Austin
Community but it is arguably one of the
most violent neighborhoods in the entire
city and so you know I have tremendous
incentive to make sure that not just my
neighborhood and my children are safe
but to make sure that the people of
Chicago are safe and the way we do that
is by investing in people there's a
direct correlation between youth
employment and violence reduction
there's a tremendous correlation between
providing mental health care their
services and reducing crime you know
this notion that the only way in which
you know we can protect the people of
Chicago and the people of of our country
is this notion of being tough you know
what is required in this moment is for
us to be smart about our investments to
be critical in our thinking and then to
make sure that what we're doing actually
works
Mr mayor-elect um in the past you have
voice support for the defund police
movement and you have since retreated
since
um why so
well it's not so much a retreat it's
more of having a better understanding of
the impetus behind that hashtag you know
look there were organizers all over the
country who wanted to work within the
confines of the system whether it was
body cam cameras dashboard cameras all
of these sort of implementations of
formations that were ostensibly provide
more accountability within law
enforcement and it didn't work you know
I'll never forget the profound words uh
former president Barack Obama you know
when he said that if he were to have a
son he would have looked like Trayvon
and then you fast forward to Mike Brown
Freddie gray you know quantonio legria
here in Chicago who was having a mental
health crisis and the only equipment on
the scenes on the scene were guns and
he's dead and Betty Jones's neighbor who
came to his defense was is dead and so
this is really about making sure that
people understand the context of the
level of frustration when you see that
type of brutalization over and over
again it certainly can be discouraging
so if defunding the police isn't the
answer what do you plan to do with your
resources is it less money or more money
to police departments
well it's it's more money towards the
the areas of needs right and as I
mentioned before you know we're working
to double the amount of young people
that we hire not just for summer jobs
but for year-round positions one of the
things that I think is actually quite
fascinating about our position here in
Chicago we've been pushing this
ordinance called treatment not trauma in
essence First Responders social workers
counselors EMT these individuals which
show up to cause that require those type
of interventions in fact in Chicago
almost 40 percent of the 9-1-1 calls are
mental health crises we're asking police
officers to do their job in someone
else's like that's not strategic in fact
sixty percent of the violence that
happens in the city of Chicago it occurs
in six percent of the cities and it
should be a surprise Mr Mayor like this
is Vlad let me just ask you then uh it
sounds great on paper but how do you pay
for it Chicago as you know is headed
towards a major deficit in 2024 you say
you're not going to raise taxes but you
have talked about perhaps other ways of
raising money including property taxes
well so I'm not going to raise property
taxes that's that's been the lazy form
of governance for a very long time in
the city of Chicago and quite frankly
around the country you know the words
that President
um Biden indicated in his Union Address
he said that a teacher and a firefighter
should not pay the same tax rate as a
millionaire and a billionaire so so Mr
Mayor elect you're not going to raise
property taxes but you will have to
raise taxes
what we're going to have to do is to
find the revenue from individuals who
have the means to actually contribute to
a safer City look the bottom line is
this we have large corporations
um 70 percent of large corporations in
the city of Chicago in the state of
Illinois did not pay a corporate tax 70
percent of large corporations in the
state of Illinois did not pay a
corporate tax and it's that type of
restraint on our budget that has caused
the type of disinvestment that has led
to Poverty of course that has led to to
violence thank you Mr mayor-elect uh
congratulations again on your Victory
let's appreciate your time
all right thank you very much